we begin tonight with a Fox News Alert
now we have been telling you that we are
expecting the results of four separate
federal investigations into the deep
state breaking tonight according to our
sources the first of those reports is
set to be released soon maybe as early
as tomorrow
the DOJ inspector general's official
findings on James Comey are now imminent
and it's not looking good for well mr.
super Patriot the guy who knows better
than us and we are told that the report
will strongly rebuke the disgraced
former FBI director document his utter
lack of candor that means lying and
we're also being told that the report in
the inspector general is putting out
tomorrow as refered call me for federal
prosecution for stealing government
documents leaking confidential
government memos that detailed
conversations with the president a clear
violation of the Espionage Act these
documents were so sensitive
one month after Comey was fired by
Donald Trump the president the FBI agent
showed up at the disgraced former
directors front door to retrieve the
memos and interrogate Comey about his
rampant misconduct and as of now the
Attorney General well he has reportedly
decided not to at this moment charge Co
me over this criminal referral however
this is what is a tiny piece of what the
bigger report will be and the three
major reports that are coming and
without a doubt Comey should be sweating
a lot tonight about what might be in
those reports this report is expected to
be the tip of the iceberg when it comes
to Jim Comey in the coming weeks when we
get the fisa full FISA abuse report by
the inspector general as we have long
reported Jim Comey is playing a starring
role in that investigation remember he's
signed three of those FISA applications
all of them he had been warned about on
multiple occasions all of them the bulk
of information Hillary Clinton's bought
and paid for Russian dossier what the
New York Times now refers to as Oh
likely Russian disinformation from the
get-go
that's where premeditated fraud on the
FISA Court for the purpose of spying on
a presidential candidate a
president-elect and a
President of the United States were all
obtained under false pretenses fraud
before a court and were also used in an
attempt to destroy a duly elected
president that's how serious this all
gets we're also awaiting what will
ultimately be the Durham bar report on
what are the origins of the Russia probe
now this report will dig into how
America's powerful tools of intelligence
were used and abused against President
Trump's campaign and then President
Trump and also whether in fact the
illegal spying occurred the outsourcing
of intelligence gathering to friendly
countries like Italy Great Britain and
Australia all designed to circumvent US
laws against spying against Americans
without a warrant for the purpose of
destroying a duly elected president that
will be a bombshell James Comey is also
implicated in that particular case we
also wait to see what roles James
clapper John Brennan played in all of
this also Andy McCarthy as he points out
in his brand-new book there is no such
thing as a counterintelligence
investigation unless the President of
the United States was involved that
would mean at some point as these
reports now come out one after another
former President Obama must be asked
under oath what did you know about your
counterintelligence investigation and
when did you know it because at some
point we will also get another report on
deep State leaking which is also a
criminal offense